lundi c'était la journée du câlin et
gilles embrasser isabelle morini-bosc
d'embrassades en embrassades de langue à
langue salive en salivent barça tient
malheureusement ça n'a pas tourné aussi
bien que dans la bouche d'isabelle
[Rires]
décrit est tombée comme un homme comme
ap sur une toile cirée gilles israël
sont embrassés moments difficiles à
oublier pour se tourner mais tous ceux
qui ont détesté il était très émue fière
car évidemment se baisser n'a pas plu à
fatou fatou sa compagne depuis longtemps
a depuis on ne peut pas ce qu'il y a et
concordance de tonnes aidez nous à même
d en coulisses fatou est remonté comme
un coucou coucou
elle a même envoyé un sms à kelly v de v
lire soir pendant l'émission
vous allez présenter vos excuses si vous
n'étiez pas là hier on vous a mis un
petit récapitulatif et on vous dira où
on est histoire de jeans et fatou je
rappelle que gilles vous êtes arrivé
lundi
on peut le dire aux téléspectateurs vous
avez trouvé vos affaires outside non
j'ai même pas été jusqu'à août side nom
est resté dans la rue non vous étiez je
suis pas voilà jeu il a passé qu'il faut
serrer la vis je voulais passer 50
minutes inside avec fatou il a passé une
nuit out ça en fait il fallait dormir à
la maison chez nous cette drogue a
annoncé
un rien à part est de mettre de l'huile
solaire car je rappelle que je n'ai pas
mine à l'appel bien sûr qu'elle n'a pas
mis la longue et ceux qui étaient dans
sa bouche on peut le remarquer
malheureusement je vous dis ce soir dans
cook et on avait des caméras dans votre
bouche regarde décidément la semaine
aura été longue pour gilles verdez dont
le buzz de la semaine n'est pas très
bien passées à la maison tout a commencé
mardi soir dans tpm paix lors de la
journée internationale des câlins sur le
plateau certains chroniqueurs avait
choisi cette journée pour déclarer leur
amour à leurs collègues autour de la
table et si on sait que gilles et
isabelle aime se prendre régulièrement
le bec sur de nombreux sujets gill a
déclaré que ces tensions étaient en
partie dû au fait qu'il aime beaucoup
isabelle dans un autre monde
on aurait une histoire c'est sûr c'est
la raison pour laquelle il a décidé de
saisir l'occasion pour l'embrasser sur
la bouche un baiser avec la langue qui
n'a pas tout à fait séduit les
chroniqueurs présents en plateau
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sont pas les seuls à avoir bloqué
dès son retour à la maison j n'a eu à
faire à sa compagne fatou qui elle non
plus n'a pas beaucoup apprécié le voir
embrasser avec la langue une autre femme
qui est regardé mon téléphone et j'avais
un sms que je vous dirai pas qu'il y
avait quatre modes fatou j'ai compris
que la sq a été fini connard résultat
hier soir gilles a donc décidé de
présenter en direct ses excuses à celle
qui partage sa vie pour parler
vulgairement j'ai déconné chérie je m'en
excuse mais chez de me rattraper je vais
te parler
je suis désolé je t'ai manqué de respect
et ce que je voudrais dire cher et c'est
que je t'aime mais une question se pose
maintenant suite à ses excuses en direct
fatou et elle pardonné à gilles alors
fatou gilles on va en parler dans un
instant ça me rappelle une histoire
drôle
gilles on en est où et kelly est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire déjà hier soir
parce qu'on va savoir déjà hier soir on
en été puisque fatou vous envoyez un sms
oui alors déjà je tenais à dire que
c'est une histoire hyper sérieuse donc
mathieu arrête de rigoler parce que ces
annonces et jérôme anthony c'est ce
qu'on dénombre arrêté là et nerveux
c'est maintenant mais s'il vous plaît
mathieu a le droit de prendre cette
histoire comme il le sent lui et rigoler
c'est sa matière de le ce de le soutenir
vous le dis je connais battu que j'en
rêve de manière quoi je dirai ce que
j'aurais à dire si vous me donnait la
parole à court bien entendu merci donc
du coup hier on s'est arrêté sur le sms
de fatou que j'ai reçue à l'antenne où
elle disait tu peux dire à isa que je ne
lui en veux pas du tout je ne blâme
qu'une seule personne et sejil oui voilà
avec apparemment ça va pas
on dit dans une merde donc du coup j'ai
pas eu le temps de lui répondre à
l'antenne une merde alors envoyé un
petit message le soir mais pour un petit
peu venté les mérites de gila m'a pas
répondu
alors gilles parce que oui pourquoi on
en parle parce que c'est vrai que sur
twitter vous avez tous dit comment ils
vont faire avec leur fourrure compagnons
et compagnes
vous savez avec votre mari après ce ce
bisou ah bah oui on ne dira sors je ne
dois pas regarder me dit non je me bats
je vais te raconter donc alors raconté
médias très bien da comme saddam à la
alain on embrasse fort et bravo à
l'impasse que fatou on peut comprendre
aussi mois moi j'ai envie je vous dis la
vérité
oui alors je savais je vous aime
beaucoup oui mais je comprends pas tout
habatjou de la vérité ouais voilà je je
je serai toujours avec vous mais c'est
vrai que fatou on peut la comprendre
est ce que vous comprenez fatou vous
chez vous c'est la question que je pose
sur twitter comprenez vous faites moi je
la comprends
eh bien on est tous à main soit vous
réponds clairement facto at elle
pardonné à gilles la réponse est non
quand on en est où là c'est une
stagnation une sorte de glaciation ça
n'a pas empiré mais c'est à dire est-ce
que vous avez des nouvelles de fatou
elle vous répond pas du tout alors elle
ne répond pas ce que je vais la voir
demain à 10 heures parce qu'elle me fait
de l'électro stimulation ayant elle me
fais du sport
non666 scemama coach de sport ça alors
il ya un peu longs beau comme ça
ah oui le mec meurt avec les haltères
donc fait gaffe et en plus vous savez
quoi cette histoire nous colombo après
il ya un mec qui l'animé et qu'ils
acquièrent au vrai crime
il ya vraiment tué l'amant de sa femme
et ses gaffes ça y est le meurtre ou pas
fait je suis ça ce qui est une
inspectrice qui se souviennent de
travaux et columbus est une série
policière ou à la peinture en bout de
cinq minutes mais c'est sympa non moi
j'ai taux de confiance en elle alors là
elle vous dit est ce qu'elle est ce que
vous avez encore du contact non même par
sms pour le rendez vous de demain
elle a répondu oui pour le rendez vous
de demain a dit ok d'accord j'ai ou
derrien bien à 10h15 à me dire oui ok
elle veut dire que demain le courant va
placer non mais on est au près qu'on est
vraiment là pour sortir des vannes
pourries ce pas une bonne programme
arrêté là là c'est sérieux là il ya deux
structures lesquels on rigole pas sur le
courant cgil et claude françois donc
arrivé
non franchement 0 le week end moi je
pense qu'on pourrait dire que c'est une
réponse professionnelle et que du coup
elle c'est comme si c'était logique
qu'elle te répond c'est parce que mes
clients de son institut mais je pense
alors elle a évidemment même temps
voulait à ce point la tortuga et je
pense que l ne t'aurais pas répondre à
six tours elle voudrait pas voir ta
gueule je vais vous dire moi j'ai un
conseil à vous donner qui est une
histoire drôle cjd un copain si vous
voulez je vous le dirai dans un instant
avez juste à moi benjamin juste parce
que je vais défendre dit c'est vrai que
moi la maison avec ça que parfois elle
prend mal les blagues les vannes externe
sinon je lui dis c'est pour l'émission
vous le voyez à fatou jeu que je la
comprends parce qu'effectivement je
comprends qu'elle a été vexé mais que
vraiment c'est ce qui se passe ici c'est
pour le show et ces voix là c'est pour
l'après pour la blague c'est pour voilà
c'est pour moi mais moi ils ont quand
même mon père connaît on arrêtait une
grande proximité de caractère entre vous
et fatou vous le sa mère dabon mais vous
le savez très bien vendus que bouffer
voilà oui dès demain chez quelque chose
fierté est là elle à votre sens de
l'honneur et voit que fierté est ce que
alors jusqu'au bout je peux vous
demander si vous voulez je vous avec
vous demain au médiateur non non non tu
as vu de pire dans un 1er temps des
tarifs je demande aux téléspectateurs
non c'est que je dois y aller avec jean
s'est enfin deux rendez-vous d'accord
j'arrivais d'abord surprise se dit
autrement sur le feu bah ça ne passait
pas une question de jalousie je pense
aller pas jaloux lui connaît elle le
prend comme une année l'ex-rn qui vais
manquer de respect écoute très vite je
vais m'adresser à fatou parce que tout
ça c'est pas une histoire d'amour c'est
une histoire d'hommes d'amour propre et
c'est pas là quand on aime quelqu'un on
laine dans son entièreté et pour ce
qu'elle est il trouve que gilles a un
métier aujourd'hui c'est un métier
d'image il fait des choses d'image
parfois ses potes ridicule parfois ça
peut être très drôle parfois c'est un
bisou
peu importe c'est son métier donc c'est
juste son ego qui était blessé on n'est
pas la personne pour une personne son
métier gilles c'est ça il a fait le show
là avec isabelle j'étais amical c'était
un baiser c'est eren plus dans une
émission on a bien rigolé je trouve
qu'elle en fasse tout un pataquès canon
mais pénible wen a indiqué fatou a passé
elle se sert de ça pour se débarrasser
de toi voilà oui ça j'avoue que j'ai
forcé alors comprenez rien
tu vois quoi allez-vous fois qu'il ya
des quatre secondes moi j'avais un
copain qui a eu un problème avec sa
femme
j'ai toujours aimé l'histoire est vrai
quand on raconte souvent c'est soi même
non non je vous jure que c'est ok donc
je lui dis je vais te dire s'il habitait
lesquels je lui dis voilà ce qu'il faut
que tu fasses je pense que je vous le
dis c'est il faut que tu arrives à la
reconquérir par l'amour donc je vous dis
tu vas rentrer chez toi sont collés et f
comme elle te parle pas tu vas aller
sous la couette et là tu vas tu m'as pas
voilà tout donné faire des trucs tout
donné voilà tu vois donc tu soulèves la
couette et tu y vas tu vois là je disais
populaire elle est pentue et lèche le
cul cul c'est vrai donc y arriver dans
les canaries comme ça c'est une robe
noire très longtemps rien il est coutume
chez un ami il entend en effet il
continue comme ça ça te parce qu'il
demi-heure ou une heure une heure et
roman il entend là c'est l'extase taillé
comme un ouf et où il dit ça y est je
vais te réconcilier avec elle hélas ici
bon allez je vais prendre un petit verre
d'eau dans la cuisine y va dans la
cuisine 1 et là elle est là sur sa femme
et il fait mais que tu fais là toi fais
ma maman qui dorment haut la main
alors
d'où le conseiller de se taper la mère
de gilles je pense que ça va s'arranger
j'espère en tout cas il faut mettre le
paquet sinon ça on lui parlait non non
non gilles est ce que vous voulez faire
ce que vous comptez faire ben j'essaye
mais c'est honnêtement vous n'êtes pas
sûr que je suis pas certain cesser la
situation est compliquée ou en tout cas
on embrasse fort feu doux et à la raison
la comprendre et on l'est hausse à tous
et voilà j'espère que ça va s'arranger
avec lille parce que gilles c'est un
super mec
je vous le dis et gilles franchement je
ferai tout ce que vous voudrez pour vous
aider dans ces gentils voilà donc on va
voir s'il aimait ou quitter paul eluard
caissière d'un poète aimait ou quitter
barre toi
nous n'avons non les gens ne veulent pas
travaux publics
[Rires]